je
[Musique]
non
bonjour
enfin
[Musique]
la ville d'athènes est l'objet d'un
récit mythique celui ci ne s'attarde pas
sur la manière dont la ville a été bâtie
ce qui reste très floue mais plutôt sur
la manière dont elles acquièrent un rôle
spécial en destin pour à kindi et ce
destin athènes le porte dans son nom en
effet cela ne vous aura pas échappé mais
athènes c'est la ville d'athéna des s
associer à la sagesse l'éducation mais
aussi à la stratégie militaire
ce mythe est connu sous plusieurs
versions
il ya un point sur lequel s'accordent
c'est le conflit qui oppose athéna et
poséidon dieu des mers pour le contrôle
de la tique la région d'athènes
rivalisant pour séduire les habitants
les deux divinités aurait offert chacune
un présent censée illustrer l'intérêt de
se ranger sous leur protection
poséidon propose aux athéniens un cheval
animal indispensable de la vie antique
utilisé pour les labours les moulins et
la guerre athena offre pour sa part un
olivier c'est sans doute moins
impressionnant que l'étalon noir de son
concurrent mais tout bien considéré il
présente aussi de nombreux avantages
il fournit évidemment l'huile une denrée
essentielle et très prisée dont on peut
faire commerce
ces rameaux symbolise également la fête
la stabilité ce dilemme entre la foule
du cheval et la sagesse de l'arbre est
bien entendu tranché en faveur de
l'olivier ce qui se nomme désormais
athénien est riche alors un sanctuaire
en l'honneur de leur nouvelle déesse
protectrice de la ville
[Musique]
oh
l'essentiel du mythe s'est déroulée sur
l'acropole ce promontoire qui
accueillait déjà des occupations
humaines monolithique
le temple est bien entendu érigé et
c'est aussi là qu'a lieu le vote des
citoyens et la démonstration de force
que deux divinités
c'est en effet cette donne aujourd'hui
un immense parc archéologique qui
constitue le coeur de la vie religieuse
et civique de la cité data et tout cela
pour une très bonne raison qu'ils
sautent aux yeux
c'est le site naturel l'acropole la
ville hôte en drag a toutes les
caractéristiques géographiques d'un lieu
mythique
c'est une forteresse naturelle et les
premiers occupants préhistoriques ont
tout de suite compris ses falaises
abruptes de plusieurs dizaines de mètres
notre un accès qu'à l'ouest au sommet
2,5 ha surplombe la mer méditerranée et
lui plein de l'attique
tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour un
récit exceptionnel
[Musique]
les versions qui ne sont pas revenues de
cette histoire parfois par des voies
détournées diffèrent sur la manière de
départager les dieux soit le choix est
fait par le premier roi mythique de la
ville
c'est crops qui choisit athéna mais fait
ériger un sanctuaire de consolation à
poséidon qui accepte sa défaite
soit il est fait par les citoyens
eux-mêmes cette dernière version qui
nous vient de varon un écrivain romain
du 1er siècle avant jésus-christ
comporte une morale un peu différent
puisque c'est par un vote des hommes et
des femmes que le dilemme est résolu les
hommes choisissent le cheval et la
guerre tandis que les femmes
majoritaires d'une seule voix se range
du côté de la sagesse et de la paix pour
faire payer cette déconvenue aux
athéniens incapables de maîtriser leurs
femmes
poséidon aurait abattu sur la ville une
vague des mesures et des athéniens
effrayer des conséquences tragiques de
cette affaire aurait alors privé leur
compagne du droit de participer aux
affaires de la cité ou comment justifier
le patriarcat par une histoire
alambiquée
non
et puis athènes englouti sous les flots
pour avoir bafoué la volonté divine
c'est un peu le mythe de l'atlantide qui
refait surface dans ce mythe poséidon
par athènes mais gagne l'atlantide comme
lot de consolation pour platon athènes
et atlantide sont liés
c'est la même cité sous deux identités
l'unprg historique et sages dirigé par
athéna et l'olivier l'autre guerrière et
maritimes après cité de poséidon campe
là tous mettent en garde les athéniens
en leur rappelant le sort de la chante
il engloutit il fait aussi référence à
cette dispute originel ou choix de la
sagesse plutôt qu'à celui de la mer
[Musique]
le fondateur le site de l'acropole
continue d'être aménagé pendant
plusieurs siècles des portes
monumentales une réserve d'armes et
plusieurs tons qu'ils sont construits
les deux principaux sont déliées
naturellement à tenir le 1er et le
parthénon chef-d'oeuvre incontournable
est visible de toute la cité qui montre
sur son fronton ouest la dispute
quant à demain et poséidon le temple est
très richement décoré mais surtout
truffé de détails et de nuances conçu
pour tricher avec notre perception
légèrement décalée par rapport à
l'entrée le temple se donne à voir
d'emblée sous son meilleur angle
il est pensé pour les yeux avant d'être
pensés pour les dieux
[Musique]
mais
le deuxième temple majeur est un édifice
plus discret est directement liée au
mythe de fondation de la ville
l'érechthéion d'apparence plus
inhabituel et délicate que son imposant
voisin l'érechthéion a été érigé sur les
lieux supposés de la dispute entre les
deux divinités il conserver en son sein
un statut primitive d'athéna fait de
bois et paradoxalement plus sacrés
respecté que son immense réplique faite
d'or et l'ivoire siégeant dans le trésor
du parthénon
ce qui fait l'importance du temple ce
n'est pas sa taille
les matériaux employés pour sa
construction ou la quantité et la
richesse des décors mais bien l'histoire
mythique qui lui est rattaché c'est elle
qui donne un sens à la pierre une
histoire de choix et de destin
aujourd'hui le même phénomène existe
passé les propylées
les porte monumentale de l'acropole
c'est encore faire acte de pèlerinage le
nuc survie comme toujours en se
transformant athéna plus qu c'est autre
chose qui se joue ici une histoire
d'image
une fois franchi ce seuil les pèlerins
utilisent ce décor mythique pour mettre
en scène leur propre mythologie coup ça
nous aventure le tout agrémenté d'une
euphorie plus ou moins complets
et c'est finalement le but poursuivi à
l'architecte du parthénon phidias en
bâtissant un décor fait pour la
photographie avant même son invention
[Musique]
oublié peut-être athéna mais se souvenir
d'athènes
[Musique]